hi guys I'm Greg I'm John on the channel
on soon will be the lovely and talented
hilarious Syd Wilder he's coming on the
channel soon John and I watched a few of
her sketches last night yeah no joke
like you gotta watch some of these go
over the sketches that we watched
yesterday that we saw had the perfect to
be an after sin la exercise la it's
[ __ ] selfie the one where she wakes up
with the german guy oh yeah what's your
name yeah Flula i think is the guy yeah
Flula but the how to take a [ __ ]
selfie was hysterical now owns yeah that
was fun perfectly crowd they're all
really funny but how to be a good to
take a [ __ ] selfie was like the was
that was my favorite one for sure we
thought like you know what let's check
out another sketch and since we seem to
keep laughing at this I want to kind of
want you guys to know more about her I
want you guys to know more about this
lovely talented youtuber actress and she
writes and I think she directs these
sketches to don't go beyond the
directing bar but I know she writes
these there's a sketch that she did
recently call thanksgiving with your new
stepmom oh boy thanksgiving is right
around the corner yeah we got over
really soon coming up you're not late on
this this is totally trending right now
I hope that this is I hope this garms a
good laugh I do too i think it will yeah
i judging by experience judging by here
let's see this love it Oh
so uh how are we related then and your
new step mommy hey you're that yeah you
remember that is the wedding you locked
yourself in the bathroom either call
security oh yeah I do remember that I
was like three or four two months ago
yeah and then you unfollowed me on
instagram after being arrested for
disturbing the peace that was expunged
so that never happens technically I
would never unfollow you well you did
she did and then she made it goes to cap
call [ __ ] sammi 16 do you see it okay
you will apologize and undo the whatever
that is instagram god you're so old i am
sincerely sorry that i unfollowed your
um what seventh 25 year old 16 you two
must no no no we're gonna have babies
[ __ ] thinking about adopting your fold I
know the perfect child I nominate result
I am I feel like I'm a child even better
ya know for something a little younger
hey well you know I can you know do that
only lets me do this once the medicine
has kicked in what is wrong with you Oh
Greg Wilson I've seen him do coffee a
bunch of time this don't cry babe
high-maintenance girlfriend on
Thanksgiving yeah man oh boy has a short
video is short short and sweet oh I
don't know that actress is
I haven't seen her in any of the other
video she's yeah she was she she's
really funny though Sid didn't like try
to make herself like the shining star of
that sketch which I thought was cool by
know she writes all these sketches when
she's good at sharing the screen and I
feel like you know she that's a great
point she's great it like she doesn't
always try to just shine like be the
only one shining she is good at letting
other people shine and her yeah in her
sketches she knows the scene is is you
know the star and and I like that you
know she seems like especially with
these where it's not just her you know
like these are character sketches you
know oh totally you know they're each
character is distinct and they're all
yeah outlandish in their own ways and
she's really good at playing like cuz
she's definitely not an idiot in real
life to be like this talented and be
able to put all these things together
man no way she's an idiot you know with
shark but she's kind of cool like she's
on an idiot in this sketch either but
she is good at playing like that
character though who's a little bit I
how would you describe her in this
sketch oh she just seems bemusedly put
out by the situation I'm not into this
but here we are the person who's like
putting up with something totally you
know it like she's the straight man I
guess of this sketch it's cool when
people take that on because not
everybody wants to play that part yeah
exactly when you can play a part well it
makes the same shine I mean weight was
kind of surprising about the setup of
this sketch it's like I've seen like a
comedy sketches or movies where they do
the you know they do the whole concept
of you know the stepmom is young and
kind of trashy gold digger personality
but there was something about the
dynamics written of these two and
especially the good performances of
these two actors that did give it a
fresh unique Flair about the the way
this is being portrayed like it was
actually funny it wasn't just
stereotypical kind of jokes you know I
think the character stuff is what really
makes this shine because yeah we have
seen you know like the awkward Oh super
young stepmom idea before but everybody
in this scene you know brings their
personality to it no way that's really
natural really funny I'm kinda nervous
to collab with her I'm yeah I don't
blame you kind of nervous you know like
I'm just kind of nervous just watching
this video think she might be watching
this video oh man reacting to it on her
own because like she's funny like really
funny
she's talented she seems like she's got
strong work ethic and she's she's
beautiful all the great qualities that
she'd wanted 10 min wallah did you and
when I'm around a woman like that which
is rare I um might I I kind of died on
the inside it's like all personality i
have and charm and humor and confidence
just it's happening now it's happening
now just the idea of her sitting here
not you yeah yeah and looking at her but
right now I see Syd Wilder alright I'm
Sid you're Gregg go hello got really
good chicken right now I wish she wasn't
talented and wasn't good looking yeah
and I would be so confident her but she
just totally sucked I would feel totally
sucked like was horrible on camera then
that's the perfect guest for me to talk
to my confidence is best when everyone
around me so is lower than really really
like I'm like below average am i okay
for her to be even lower than below
average yeah she's just like gained like
400 pounds before she comes over here at
least mean uh no I'll be confident I'll
be confident you sure I'll be confident
sure you will you I got some talent I
just feel like you know I go for like
dirty raunchy jokes when I'm nervous
yeah and she doesn't do that I don't
know yeah no no no Jesus be good totally
i'm just a bng not about edgy humour no
I can't even imagine what that would
look like I mean the thing though is is
like she has videos where she's like you
know sometimes she's half-naked in her
videos well that's what you gotta do and
I feel that her body just doesn't
compare to mine like this is sexy yes
this is confidence like she doesn't have
anywhere near as much chest hair as me
it's which this is really unattractive
my ass just looks so much better than
hers you know you don't touch it
that's right like a man smack it all
right I snap my crotch I hope she look
collab with me after doing this video
it's okay i feel like the dick deeper we
dig this hole we dig this hole deep dig
it deep in it it won't just come out the
other side right back into quality it's
so awkward I'll be coming cool you know
she's probably fine you're always fine
I'm fine a resourceful desire not just
reviewing your video it's become all
about it's become all about about how
glad learn to talk to you so guess what
this is what we go through we're nervous
because you know we respect the town
respect you yeah yeah we respect to Tony
alright guys we'll check out Syd Wilder
channel seriously she's coming on the
channel now hopefully she still will be
and subscribe to our channel check out
the social media links are on the
description box for John I don't want to
say it all right now it's too much and
we've talked too much social media sorry
and um I vote that hacksaw Ridge is the
best movie about Christianity starring a
Jewish guy oh is this integral juche
mm-hmm that's cool he's also playing a
priest in silence he is the go-to
question denomination Jewish actor
that's a good god man divers in
Hollywood